[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar de la política y el
deporte Y es que este mundial de fútbol
de Qatar no ha estado ajeno a la
polémica y también muchos de los
conflictos geopolíticos actuales se ven
de cara y se ven reflejados en las
canchas Como por ejemplo los partidos
entre Estados Unidos versus Irán Francia
túnez y el apoyo de los iraníes a los
ingleses en rechazo al gobierno islámico
de su país en el marco de estas
protestas sociales tras la muerte de
maxam Mini donde también hoy
precisamente las iraníes se volcaron
contra su gobierno en apoyo a puede ser
que se esclarezca todo esta muerte de
maximena apoyo a las protestas saludamos
a Manuel Medina del ex periodista
internacional con enfoque deportivo y
político gracias a Manuel por estar con
nosotros esta mañana de viernes en
directo América de Francia 24 empezamos
con un contexto Y cómo estas diferencias
políticas saltan al terreno de juego en
este mundial de Qatar
Hola qué tal Raúl y a toda la gente que
nos está viendo Pues sí la cuestión
política siempre va de la mano con la
organización de estos eventos sobre todo
de la Copa del Mundo desde 1930 que
inició
las controversias de los siguientes dos
mundiales en el 34 y en el 38 en en
Alemania y en una Italia en tiempos
prácticamente ya de guerra y bueno
Qatar ha sido muy criticados desde hace
12 años por precisamente estos problemas
que ha tenido tanto desde la
construcción de los estadios hasta los
Derechos Humanos e incluso los derechos
de la comunidad lgbt Así es Manuel
tocaba un punto muy importante y es que
esto no comienza digamos Cuando comenzó
mundial sino dos años atrás sino que
evidentemente cuando inició ya este
evento deportivo pues ya las críticas
fueron aún muchísimo más fuertes Cómo se
utiliza digamos el deporte con
como una herramienta política digamos en
el caso de Qatar le benefició para
blanquear su imagen a nivel
internacional no de alguna manera
Sí claro el deporte desde siempre se ha
utilizado para intentar que los vean a
esto a este tipo de gobiernos con buenos
ojos no tratando de mostrar su cultura
demostrar Obviamente el mejor lado que
tiene la mejor cara posible y bueno esto
ha sido en diferentes partes del mundo
no ahora en Qatar en el medio oriente
por ejemplo con los mundiales de Clubes
que se han llevado a cabo en los
emiratos árabes Unidos ahora en Qatar
también hubo un Mundial de Clubes en
Qatar previo Ahora les dan también eh la
copa árabe están dando muchos muchos
eventos y bueno eh la gente en Francia
misma sabe de esto no estos poderosos
gobiernos que cumplan compran incluso
clubes de fútbol para poder traer aquí
en la playera no el nombre del país el
nombre de la aerolínea el nombre de la
empresa y de alguna manera intentar
limpiar al menos Durante un mes lo que
dura el torneo Pues de limpiar un
poquito su imagen y dar a enseñar lo que
ellos quieren enseñar Claro sin embargo
Manuel no se puede ser ciego ante todo
lo que está pasando también mencionadas
en la introducción a nuestro tema de
temas a importantes como la libertad de
expresión ncantar también los derechos
de la comunidad lgbti Alemania por
ejemplo también lo vimos o con esta
expresión de tapándose la boca como
diciendo en este país no hay libertad de
expresión finalmente no pudieron usar el
brazalete One Love en apoyo a la
comunidad lgbti porque si no eh Pues
corrían sanciones de que los sacaran de
de la cancha o tarjeta amarilla entonces
pues vemos absolutamente todo esto
precisamente hoy también las iraníes en
las gradas con camisetas que decían maxa
mini también eh maquilladas con Lágrimas
de sangre entonces la sociedad civil
también tiene un rol bien importante en
estos eventos deportivos no
Sí claro De hecho hoy se puede hablar
precisamente ya que tocas el tema de
Irán la manera en que todos los
aficionados se Irán lloraban al cantar
su himno hoy antes del partido ante
gales después la manera en que
festejaron por poder conseguir una
victoria histórica en las copas del
mundo y esto así como el deporte de
repente se utiliza para una herramienta
política también ayuda mucho a que la
gente pueda sentirse un poquito feliz no
sobre todo en este momento lo que sufre
la gente dirán las las aficionadas de
Irán precisamente llorando porque son
libres fuera de su país no en este caso
a mí me tocó por ejemplo en San
Petersburgo en el mundial de Rusia del
2018 yo entrevista varias aficionadas
donde me decían Es que aquí me puedo
vestir como yo quiero aquí puedo andar
sin vuelo y puedo ir a las gradas
alentar a mi equipo entonces Imagínate
lo importante que es eso y bueno ya si
le damos la cuestión también geopolítica
de esto ahora Estados Unidos todavía
jugar pero pase lo que pase se va a
jugar prácticamente su clasificación a
la siguiente ronda contra Irán y bueno
Tú sabes que políticamente hablando
Estos son dos enemigos ideológicos claro
es que bueno quería tocar también el
tema de la libertad de expresión
precisamente con estas muestras de apoyo
de las iraníes a las protestas en su
país porque precisamente la policía de
Qatar fue a las gradas a pedirles que
por favor se retiraran porque no podían
estar haciendo este tipo de
manifestaciones entonces también es la
libertad de expresión no encatar donde
se juega esto y también ese ese juego
que estaba mencionando de Irán a contra
Estados Unidos también que las tensiones
Se volvieron en un punto máximo Por así
decirlo en el 2018 cuando el presidente
Donald Trump se retiró unilateralmente
de este acuerdo nuclear Y entonces las
tensiones Todavía están ahí como a flor
de piel no como estos estos eventos o
también estos sorteos ponen toda la
geopolítica en el terreno de juego
también tenemos un juego entre túnez y
Francia qué podemos decir esto
sí los siempre los países que en algún
momento fueron colonias Argelia y
Francia o que tienen que son vecinos y
que han tenido algunos problemas por
ejemplo Irán Arabia Saudita Corea del
Sur Japón siempre tienen algún Pique no
e incluso ya yéndonos por ejemplo a
latinoamérica Argentina Por ejemplo si
se enfrenta a Inglaterra siempre hay ese
esa cuestión política no que utilizan
los los aficionados para intentar hacer
enojar al al contrario no en
Latinoamérica ya tuvimos Lamentablemente
una guerra del fútbol así se le conoce
No a ese enfrentamiento tanto en la
cancha como en los problemas migratorios
en 1969 entre El Salvador y Honduras
Imagínate qué triste que que nuestra
latinoamérica Tuvimos una guerra del
fútbol donde no solo era los 90 minutos
sino que también hubo problemas de
trifulcas hubo problemas causados por el
resultado que hasta tuvo que llegar un
tercer partido jugado en un sitio
neutral como la Ciudad de México
precisamente porque había una guerra la
llamada La guerra de los de las 100
horas no en en Entonces es algo que
calienta ánimos por ejemplo hoy Estados
Unidos enfrentándose a Inglaterra eh
Aunque ya hay una amistad entre los dos
países obviamente siempre hay un pique
pequeño ahí entre ellos dos y lo que te
decía lo que puede suceder si Irán se
enfrenta árabes ahorita en este mundial
si Inglaterra se enfrenta Argentina en
este mundial pues obviamente va más allá
de ya nada más la pelota y los 90
minutos sino que se vuelve un poquito de
de a ver qué régimen o qué ideología